कि खड़ा जी मैंने तुम जैसा बेवकूफ इंसान आज तक नहीं देखा आए ना देख लेते सरकार वो तो मैं तुम्हें बाद में दिखा दूंगा तो प्रलू की हत्या अमित और सुनीता ने नहीं की गर्रेक्ट वो सीडियो से गिर कर मर गया स्टैम पेपर पर लिखका द
हचे तूह दोख दोख हमाइन कन वहाँ साथ डाषा नोजवाल तो दुम मीरे जैसा छे पूटा इंसान उड़िए ञाए
तुम भी किनके ओए याउ myös लिद्या दॉख ये उसकी नफ track सिक दी आ studio कि इसकी अफ मेel skipping अधार फर में संही com
जाने कि उसकी मौत…
रेफरिजेटर के अंदर हुई है
मरड़
हत्य है
और हत्य हला वो हुआ
जिसने उसे उठाकर रेफरिजेटर के अंदर डाला
क्या तुम्हे उसे रेफरिजेटर के अंदर डाला?
मै дов...
मैने उसे फ्रीजेटर के अंदर डाला
क्यों कि नालाइक अलाद में तरी खोबड़ी तुर दूगा तुम दोनों साले साफ सपोले मेरी अर्थी उठाने का प्लैन बना रहे हो शुट्या होता है
यहानर क्योंकि इनका के सब आइने की तरह साफ हो गया है